kaufkraftparitäten theorie kaufkraft
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir spielen heute
wieder jump league mit einer neuen
stelle zwar der marshmallow change für
jeden job für den ich mache muss ich mir
einen marshmallow in den mund stecken
und am ende jedes moduls sagt max mir
ein wort vor dass ich nach sprechen muss
wenn ich es richtig nach spreche dass
mir gut beenden weitergehen wenn ich auf
falsch nach speicher zum beispiel weil
ich zu viel beispiel das im und hab dann
darf ich nur weiter wenn ich einen alten
groppe was max bestimmen darf
und falls das zu kompliziert war legen
jetzt erstmal los und fangen an zu
spielen
wie gesagt für jeden job fail wird
einmal der chor ob das ist ein bisschen
vom prinzip her wie diese giabbani
challenge falls ihr die can't dance
bekannt war sie mal ein bisschen länger
da ging es darum wünscht sich ganz viele
maschinen in den mund und sagt an
shabani bis man es nicht mehr sagen kann
wer mehr dabei rein bekommt eine homo
nachhaltiger spd mehr dabei reine kommt
wird uns noch sein kann gewinnen das
essen ist auch das leckere marmelade
aufgepasst jetzt nicht so
statt von 1 egal
die nach seiner gesundheit verloren
nein was jetzt beginnt der lustige
kam mit ausgerenkten kiefer besser
spielen kaufkraftparitäten theorie
kaufkraft aufkauf kaufkraftparität
theorie verschieben
die zähne dazwischen
ich finds ja
du musst nicht zum nächsten check ich
habe jetzt nicht verstanden aber so ich
hoffe du schaffst es zum nächsten
checkpoint an ob ich irgendwas richtig
klasse
so stinken abseitsfalle falsch
also ich glaube das muss ich erstmal
nächsten und es ist immer richtig
nicht so auf dich also hatten so sah es
zumindest für mich aus dann kannst du
denn den weg zumindest mitnehmen ok sehr
gut rein
die maus lösen sich langsam auch
deswegen kann ich drücken
ob ich konnte drei wochen alter säugling
schippert stunden
oh ja nicht im sommer
man kann nur reden es ist so hart noch
wirklich nachgedacht sich noch neue
herrchen bonität ist auch woanders
hingehen
du musst die holt jubel